people of the internet's retro record
tour here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and it sounds
like The Witcher multiplayer game is in
a bit of trouble thanks to a recent
regulatory report from CD projekt Red
the multiplayer Witcher game codenamed
project serious we'll soon see a new
framework does that mean reboot
personally I didn't even know a
multiplayer Witcher game was in
development until I saw the news about
this recent update if you missed it it
may have been because they announced the
project back in October of 2022
alongside a flurry of other big
announcements including a brand new
Witcher Trilogy as well as a major
cyberpunk expansion included in all of
these announcements was Project serious
which was initially described as an
Innovative Take On The Witcher Universe
telling an unforgettable story for
existing Witcher fans and new audiences
it's being developed by the Molasses
Flood a boston-based studio founded in
2014 that's behind titles the flame in
the flood and Drake Hollow jumping ahead
to January of 2023 a series of senior
job listings were posted for project
sirius on CD project Red's website those
listings caught the eyes of fans and
gave us an early indication that the
game should have co-op as well as PVE in
addition to a class system and social
activities they were hiring for a senior
multiplayer designer that should be
highly passionate about multiplayer
games and systems game modes class
design player progression social
activities Etc a listing for a narrative
director position also mentioned
branching and non-linear storytelling
fast forward now to March of 2023 and
this is where things appear to take a
turn what we have is this very formal
statement from CD projekt Red notifying
shareholders of a decision to establish
a impairment allowance regarding project
Sirius there are really two sections we
should highlight the first one is here
saying this is a formal statement to
announce their quote decision regarding
the establishment in the company's books
of an impairment allowance with regard
to expenses incurred in the scope of
development work related to project
serious which is under development at
the Molasses Flood Studio they also make
a note here at the bottom that this is
being translated so there could be some
discrepancies here and things may not
translate perfectly and then here's the
big line at the end the aforementioned
decision is based on results of
evaluation of the scope and Commercial
potential of the original concept of
project serious and ongoing work on
formulating a new framework for this
project so what we have here is a
situation where CD projekt Red poured a
lot of money into research and
development on an initial framework for
project serious but even after spending
what converts to just under 10 million
USD they don't feel good about the
commercial viability of the original
concept and many are interpreting this
new framework bit here to essentially
mean the project is getting a reboot I
suppose the good news here is that if
you were looking forward to this it's
not canceled but the bad news here is
that the project will be undergoing a
reboot and is even further out than it
was before either way the project was
already going to be a long ways off but
now with this announcement almost
certainly not going to be something
we'll see anytime soon now as for the
other Witcher games project Polaris is
set to be the next entry in the mainline
series which they describe as a story
driven open World RPG built on the
legacy of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
they're also referring to it as the
beginning of a brand new Witcher Trilogy
and the last we heard on that one is
that they're aiming to deliver all three
games of the trilogy within a six-year
window now we still don't know the exact
data when that's coming out or even a
target for that we don't even know the
official name all we do know is that
once that first one does release they're
hoping that the full Trilogy will be out
within six years which is a pretty
exciting and pretty ambitious
considering all that they have going on
all of these Witcher updates are
something I'm sure we'll continue to
hear about over the next few years if
you'd like to see us cover those updates
here on the channel make sure to leave a
like on the video and honestly if you'd
prefer we don't make any more videos on
it leave a thumbs down and that will
help me decide if you want to see more
videos like this as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon